بس حكيم وخلصونا الاوكرانيه روسلاف يانو
شيبيتش مقطع فيديو يظهر عمل فرق الاطفاء
في اخماد نيران اندلعت عقبه استهداف
القوات الروسيه ليله الماضيه موقفا
للسيارات في خرسون جنوبيه اوكرانيا وقال
حاكم المدينه ان القصفه الروسيه تسبب
بتدمير ثلاث سيارات خدمه لعمال طاقه
واتلاف حظيره الى جانب الحاقه اضرارا
بمعدلات اخرى
للمزيد حول التطورات الميدانيه
مراسله الجزيره سلام خضر ومن خير صن مراسل
الجزيره والبدايه من الجنوب الاوكراني من
خيرسون وعمليات القصف المتبادل المستمره
على هذه الجبهه
نعم حسن اتواجد الان في قلب المدينه الذي
يتعرض لي القصف في هذه الاثناء والقصف
والقصف المتبادل موجات النزوح ما زالت
تتواصل خارج المدينه بناء على دعوات
السلطات الاوكرانيه للسكان بضروره النزوح
بضروره مغادره المدينه باتجاه مدن اخرى
اكثر امانا واقل تضررا بالحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تحديدا في مناطق وسط وغرب
اوكرانيا قبل قليل عدنا من منطقه نهر
دنيبر في خيرسون بناء على دعوات من الجيش
الاوكراني الذي طلبنا بسرعه المغادره في
المباشر السابق رصدنا همم تطورات الاوضاع
على الضفه التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه كان هنالك قصف متبادل ومستمر
بين همم الاوكران والروس هذا القصف
بالمدفعيه يجري من الطرف الاوكراني ومن
الطرف الروسي ايضا
مقابل تتحدث السلطات الاوكرانيه عن قصف
اخر تشنه القوات الروسيه باتجاه عدد من
القرى والبلدات الواقعه على خطوط التماسره
صدنا الاوضاع في تلك الكره هذه الكره او
تلك القرى افرغت الى حد كبير من السكان
بسبب الدعوات الدعوات السلطات المحليه هنا
للمغادره ايضا التطورات فيما يخص البنيه
التحتيه متواصله على صعيد انقطاعات واسعه
في التيار الكهربائي وفي المياه هنا في
خير سون في ميكولاي في اوديسا في عديد
المقاطعات الجنوبيه وذلك نتيجه للضربات
الروسيه المكثفه وفقا لالسلطات الاوكرانيه
على البنيه التحتيه وايضا في الكره
الارضيه تواصل القصف الروسي كما تقول
السلطات هناك على المناطق الساحليه تحديدا
منطقه الشوكه في منطقه ستروبري هذه
المناطق وغيرها من المناطق الساحليه
القريبه ايضا من غير سو شهد مواجهات بين
الطرفين بالمدفعيه وتطورات نهايه في
زاباروجي حيتقلا عمده المقاطعه بان قصف
الاوكرانيا متواصلا يجري على مدينه
ميليتوبل التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
في ريف زمولوجيا وتحدث عن قتلى وجرحى في
صفوف القوات الروسيه